bonjour
Eric verte bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
notre invité politique ce matin des
petits renaissance de l'Oise en étant ça
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Stéphane Vernet de
Ouest-France bonjour Stéphane bonjour
bonjour
à la pompe un tiers des stations-service
du pays connaît des pénuries hier soir
Elizabeth borne a réuni les ministres à
Matignon mais aucune décision n'est
sorti de cette réunion est-ce que le
gouvernement ne tarde pas trop à réagir
d'un sujet qui a plusieurs jours et
évidemment pénurie je sais bien qu'on
peut tourner autour du mot pendant
longtemps comme on peut tourner autour
d'une station essence mais il y a
pénurie pour ceux qui ne trouvent pas
pour ceux qui ne trouvent pas d'essence
il suffit d'aller juste se promener sur
le terrain je suis allé dans ma
circonscription dimanche faire le tour
des des pompes pour voir ce que ça
donnait suite du département de l'Oise
il y avait 85% 90% des pompes qui
étaient et dans celle qui n'étaient pas
fermées il y avait des dizeurs ou des 9
heures du matin le dimanche dès que qui
devenaient déjà insupportables donc et
bien pénurie d'essence pour celles et
ceux qui peuvent pas remplir leur
réservoir à aller travailler sans parler
évidemment des services publics il est
urgent de d'agir il y a une question
d'ordre public là dedans me semble-t-il
on voit quelques extrêmes on peut pas
croire que tous les reportages télé
valent pour l'ensemble mais enfin on
voit évidemment un énervement dans
l'ensemble de ces longues files
d'attentes et comment peut-il en être
autrement il faut agir comment Bruno
retailleux dimanche il a dit il faut des
réquises vous êtes d'accord avec ça oui
oui il faut utiliser tous les tous les
moyens disponibles alors le premier
moyen disponible c'est d'accélérer la
négociation entre puisque c'était une
question qui ne regarde pas directement
l'État à l'État n'a pas provoqué cela
c'est pas une décision de l'État c'est
pas le gouvernement le gouvernement n'a
rien à voir dans dans ce qui a déclenché
ce conflit mais il y a visiblement une
question de
social et salariale surtout entre des
entre total ou
Ouesso et les propres salariés dans les
raffineries bon il faut essayer
d'avancer il faut essayer d'avancer
maintenant très vite et si cette ce
dialogue social de naboutit pas à la
levée aujourd'hui ou demain enfin c'est
maintenant c'est dans quelques heures de
ces de ces blocages de cette prise en
totale des Français et de beaucoup de
Français il faut utiliser tous les
moyens légaux disponibles d'abord il
faut continuer à remplir les légumes
avec des les réserves stratégiques du
pays il faut accélérer ça c'est pas
assez rapide il faut que les préfets
puissent
mieux organiser les choses dans leur
propre département certains l'avaient
fait et d'autres ne l'avaient pas fait
visiblement donc mon Dieu que de temps
passé pour interdire aux Français de de
mettre de l'essence dans leur jerrican
quoi il y a une il y a un peu de lumière
mais il est pas arrivé trop tard le
gouvernement l'avait dit donc il y a des
préfets qui en effet dans l'Oise on
avait interdit les jerricanes depuis
déjà plusieurs plusieurs jours c'était
absolument normal de stocker aux dépens
aux dépens des autres vous avez Olivier
et puis les réquisitions bien sûr
réquisition de personnel c'est possible
lorsqu'il y a atteintes à l'ordre public
ça nécessite un certain nombre de de
évidemment de de de
respect de la loi sur le sur le sujet
puisque c'est une atteinte au droit de
grève mais il faut le faire sans tarder
il y a évidemment une atteinte
aujourd'hui à l'ordre public en France
bref il faut agir alors Olivier Véran
appelle ce matin à déblocage sans délais
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il pense aux
réquisition parce que comment est-ce
qu'on peut faire je ne sais pas quoi
Olivier Véran pense mais enfin en tout
cas il montre que le gouvernement a pris
conscience du sujet et maintenant avec
la avec la puissance mais aussi les
limites de l'action gouvernementale dans
ce type de cas il faut le faire c'est
qu'en cas de réquisition vous avez les
grévistes qui qui promettent une
généralisation du conflit enfin qui sont
qui sont oui mais non contre il faut
qu'on arrête d'avoir peur dans notre
pays doudou le conflit il est là euh les
Français qui attendent et qui passent un
temps fou et perdre un temps fou et tout
ça c'est des heures de travail tout ça
c'est de la tout ça c'est de la
productivité tout ça c'est de la
production tout ça c'est beaucoup de
choses en même temps donc on avait pas
besoin de on avait pas besoin de cela
non je dis pas que le gouvernement
rappeur je dis que globalement
généralement on a toujours tendance à
remettre à demain ce qu'on peut faire
aujourd'hui et ça ne change il faut
aujourd'hui agir oui oui il faut il faut
agir il faut mettre fin à cette cette
situation sociale qui vient se greffer à
une situation
structurelle ou les Français sont
inquiets ou chacun se pose plein de
questions pour soi-même pour son avenir
même si l'économie française va bien et
même si l'emploi va bien donc il y a
plein de raisons de se réjouir il y a
plein de raisons de réformer d'accélérer
les travaux de réforme de mobiliser
l'ensemble du dialogue politique afin de
réformer notre pays plutôt que de perdre
son temps dans un conflit salarial alors
que honnêtement si j'ai bien compris les
salariés de du pétrole n'ont pas trop à
se plaindre de la du niveau de leur de
leur sexe sur les chiffres qu'avant
total mais les chiffres avancés par
Total sont très contestés en fait vous
approuvez ce projet bien sûr écouter que
les choses soient sur la table enfin les
gens trouvent pas ils vont faire des
kilomètres je vais quand même c'est pas
d'abord se faire un secret défense il me
semble pas donc non je pense que Total
se garderait bien d'évoquer des chiffres
qui seraient faut donc c'est c'est
brillant moyenne ça veut dire qu'il y a
des gens qui gagnent beaucoup plus
moyenne en brume tout compris c'est
votre salaire avec la participation avec
avec de l'intéresse on parle pas du tout
des mêmes niveaux de rémunération
écoutez on travaille 32 heures il y a
des conditions c'est bien sûr que c'est
des 3 8 enfin il y a plein mais enfin on
est en France quand même généralement on
fait très attention à tout cela et et je
laisse les Français
je demande pas la baisse des salaires de
de ces de ces personnes enfin dans ce
cas-là
notage la plupart des des Français qui
ont besoin évidemment de mobilité c'est
exode apparemment il y a des
négociations en cours pour qu'ils
pourraient aboutir alors que on sent
bien que chez Total on est sur un local
dans ces négociations je ne sais pas ce
qui se passe entre les syndicats et leur
et l'employeur c'est pas à moi de
commenter ça mais on fait en tout cas il
faut sortir de cette de cette situation
très vite puisqu'on parle de Total qui
est le plus grand groupe pétrolier
français qui a fait des bénéfices
importants le gouvernement a déposé un
amendement budget qui prévoit de créer
une contribution temporaire de
solidarité pour les entreprises du
secteur du pétrole du charbon du
raffinage et du gaz finalement c'est une
taxe sur les super profits qui ne
dépassant
d'abord il faut pas taxer faut pas
surtaxer peut-être qu'il y a des surpris
je sais pas trop ce que ça veut dire il
y a des profits supplémentaires dû à la
situation et en tout cas la France c'est
déjà le pays qui taxe plus donc elle
surtaxe déjà la France par rapport à
tous les autres pays et aucun
parce que c'est c'est l'Europe c'est
c'est le la réplique exacte la
transcription exacte de la décision
prise par les Européens de taxer les
énergéticiens sur les profils
supplémentaires donc ça c'est une bonne
décision c'est une décision collective
européenne donc ça veut pas dire qu'il y
a un pays qui joue contre l'autre qui
change de cherche à attirer si ou ça
donc c'est au contraire c'est c'est une
bonne décision à toutes les décisions
qui sont prises sur le plan et européen
me vont bien parce qu'on voit bien qu'on
a besoin de puissance et la puissance
elle est aussi en Europe et cette crise
a montré d'ailleurs que l'Europe pouvait
être puissante lorsqu'elle savait
s'organiser Dieu sait que le chemin est
compliqué Dieu sait que c'est difficile
donc bravo le gouvernement français il a
beaucoup porté cette cette accord
européen il faut le mettre il faut le
mettre en oeuvre
l'examen du budget tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire que ça finira ça se
terminera par un 49-3 pourquoi attendre
parce que ce serait assez curieux de de
ne pas discuter enfin il faut bien j'en
sais rien
dans ce domaine là il y a pas un truc
qui dit c'est blanc ou c'est noir il
faut regarder comment se passe le débat
hier il y a eu deux motions de la à
l'extrême gauche de rejoindre il était
d'émotions de rejet du débat en fait
c'est curieux il disait le débat le
débat le débat en dialogue pas et puis
une motion pour dire STOP arrêtons le
débat et enfin bon ces gens sont
toujours à la limite limite de
l'incohérence complète en prenant des
contradictions permanentes bon il y a
une brutalité du débat parce que
nupes et la bonne pas une grande partie
de nupestre à une vision violente du du
débat c'est le cas oui oui oui une
violon il y a une vraiment une violence
dans le débat dans la la l'interruption
sans arrêt des orateurs dans le
non-respect de ce que disent les uns et
les autres enfin bref il n'est pas un
moment on est on est typiquement dans la
dans l'Obs parlementaire on est pas loin
de l'obstruction alors il y a des
raisons techniques qui font qu'il y a un
peu plus d'amendements que l'année
dernière mais on va pas on va pas
revenir là-dessus mais c'est évidemment
extrêmement difficile
chacun a indiqué que il ne voterait pas
le budget donc ils ont mis sur la table
dès le départ la conclusion du débat
comme la conclusion du débat c'est de
pas voter c'est donc un débat qui est en
impasse plus que les oppositions
agrégées de LR à nups en passant par le
rassemblement national ont décidé qu'il
ne voteraient pas et ils l'ont dit avant
même d'entamer ce débat tout ça c'est
une impasse donc si tu n'as pas
politique il faut pas non plus perdre
trop de temps il y a beaucoup de temps
il y en a besoin de beaucoup de temps
pour faire plein d'autres choses donc il
faut que le débat ait lieu que les vrais
débat et lieux il y a un débat sur la
dette qui a été très intéressant en fin
de en fin de soirée jusqu'à jusqu'à
minuit et c'est très important de parler
de la dette aujourd'hui française et
puis il y en a débat sur les
collectivités local débat sur le
prélèvement européen c'est évidemment on
va parler tout ça notamment de
programmation des finances publiques qui
a été repoussée en commission alors que
c'est une obligation européenne et qu'on
doit tenir nos obligations et respecter
les traités européens et honnêtement ne
pas voter pour cette cette
planification cette programmation
financière est un peu un peu surprenante
ça complique nos relations avec l'Europe
on peut pas essayer de d'avoir le
leadership de l'Europe et repousser une
trajectoire financière qui certes donne
3% en 2027 alors ça pourrait être plus
ambitieux mais ça correspond aussi pour
être quand même à ce que la France peut
faire mais vous vous écrivez une impasse
vous écrivez très bien l'impasse
politique dans laquelle on se trouve
est-ce qu'il y a pas une position
médiane ou un moyen d'en sortir sans se
dédire ce serait de pratiquer la
politique de la chaise vide c'est-à-dire
que des députés les républicains pour ne
pas voter le budget ou voir des députés
rationnant national pour ne pas voter ce
budget
nous participent pas du tout au vote au
moment où il faudrait conclure et
permettre du coup à la majorité de
passer à moi qui fait la stratégie de
l'opposition donc faut leur demander
scénario là est possible de leur
demander à eux ce qu'il est envisageable
non c'est rien je ne sais pas ce qu'ils
feront demander la demander à LR il y a
beaucoup de de d'ailleurs à poser
beaucoup de d'amendements c'est le
premier parti avoir des enfin c'est le
premier producteur de d'amendement donc
on verra bien ce que contiennent c'est
ces amendements il y a eu un débat hier
soir sur la question de la dette Édouard
Philippe dans Le Parisien dimanche ça la
remet un peu du fait que la France a un
objectif de retour aux 3% à 2027 alors
que les autres pays européens ont le
même objectif pour 2025 est-ce que vous
dites vous aussi que ça va trop
lentement moi je regarde à la fois
cette trajectoire 3% c'est sûr que c'est
évidemment trop c'est un retour c'est un
retour vers le futur mais mais ce serait
bien d'y arriver et donc déjà
et oui mais ce que ce que ne dit pas
Edward c'est que ce qui compte aussi
c'est le niveau de notre croissance tout
ça tout ça se tient de beaucoup donc on
nous avons aujourd'hui moins d'inflation
que l'Europe due d'ailleurs à la dépense
publique donc vous voyez que ça se tient
fortement nous avons aussi plus de
croissance on a rebondi plus vite que
d'autres pays on a on est en route je
l'espère vers le plein emploi ce qui
était nouveauté absolue et voyez bien
qu'il y a des tensions sur le marché de
l'emploi aujourd'hui donc le
l'augmentation de la croissance est
fondamentale et par exemple dans ce
budget il y a beaucoup de dépenses le
premier à lutter contre ça depuis très
très longtemps il y a beaucoup de
dépenses de protection des Français et
en réalité il est impossible de ne pas
si nous ne protégeons pas les Français
ça dure et c'est ça coûte encore plus
cher et si on ne protège pas les
français ce qui est sûr c'est que les
conditions pour réussir à réformer le
pays elles sont pas là du tout mais
alors pas du tout donc on est bien
obligé de le faire il faut le faire il
faut le faire de façon de plus en plus
ciblée il faut que le coût de la
protection soit inférieur à son résultat
sur la croissance il faut que la
croissance sur la pour la France cette
croissance potentielle supplémentaire
que nous attendons depuis maintenant
bien longtemps l'objectifs
il faut garder cet objectif de ligne 27
si on peut faire mieux tant mieux il
faut interroger challenger l'efficacité
de la dépense sur tout il y a pas de
résultats magique souvent on dit ah bah
oui mais alors où est-ce que vous allez
faire des économies tous les partis tous
les partis politiques produisent des
trucs pour dire il faut lutter contre
l'afrod il faut moins de bureaucratie il
faut aussi il faut ça mais la vérité
c'est que évidemment beaucoup plus
compliqué que cela c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que cela quand on est un parti
de gouvernement on essaie de rentrer
dans le détail et donc le détail si en
réalité dépense par dépenses interrogées
l'efficacité de la dépense publique le
gouvernement y est à peu près tout est
dans les cartons sur ce type de sujet
faut juste avoir une vision très
cohérente des choses et lancer les
lancer les transitions obligatoires
est-ce que vous êtes alors vous parlez
de transition obligatoire ce que vous
êtes en train de nous décrire sur la
situation notamment de l'endettement du
pays cette histoire de trajectoire
est-ce que c'est ça qui fait l'urgence
de la réforme des retraites est-ce que
c'est réforme elle est pas là pour
donner des gages à nos partenaires
européens à Bruxelles en disant certes
on va on a une tragé on va mettre un peu
plus de temps que les autres pour
revenir aux 3%. mais regardez on est de
bonne volonté à côté de ça on va aller
très vite sur la réforme des retraites
qui promènent et des économies dans la
durée de retraite vous comprenez que
tous les 10 ans faut à peu près bouger
un peu le système la réforme des
retraites c'est un gage non pas donné à
l'Europe c'est un gage donné aux
Français c'est un gage donné aux actifs
qui payent les retraites des retraités
c'est un gage donné retraités pour qu'il
continue à percevoir une pension qui ne
soit pas amputée c'est un gage donné
aux travailleurs qui paye des
cotisations
sur ce sujet par urgence sur le sujet de
la retraite mais oui mais parce que on
réfléchit toujours pour lundi prochain
temps en temps on a le droit de
réfléchir à plus longtemps et quand on
est au gouvernement on a le devoir de le
faire donc il y a des urgences
immédiates la crise de des stations
essence mais il y a des urgences aussi à
moyen terme et donc il faut les engager
des retraites et nous avons besoin mais
oui parce que à partir c'est ça dépend
des études enfin dans dans quelques
années on sera à nouveau dans un déficit
extrêmement important du système de
retraite et donc il faut bien que ce
système de retraite on le on le on le
modifie pour éviter cela et accepter les
déficits sur les systèmes de retraite
c'est accepter d'être d'une injustice
profonde avec les générations qui vont
nous suivre
vous ne pouvez pas mettre des charges
supplémentaires sur le dos des actifs
qui en ont déjà beaucoup alors que vous
devez effectivement à un moment donné
autoriser quelqu'un en fonction d'un âge
en fonction d'une durée de cotisation de
de partir à leur épaisse et acceptable
et responsable on va juste courir
pendant l'impression qu'ils trouvent le
gouvernement un peu timoré il faut aller
jusqu'à 60 ans parce que 67 ans
c'est cet âge qui
en cours de de
d'application écouter
j'en reste à l'idée que 65 ans est un
bon âge il faut du temps
il faut passer par 63 par 64 on peut un
moment donné se revoir pour regarder si
c'est nécessaire il faut évidemment
tenir compte des carrières mais ça tombe
bien c'est déjà le cas c'est déjà le cas
la France le fait il faut changer le
regard de ce qu'est un senior au travail
donc les entreprises et le patron du
Medef la raison de le dire moi je le
clame depuis bien longtemps c'est aussi
un regard sur la société c'est pas un
sujet comptable c'est un sujet de
citoyenneté ça complètement ça n'a rien
à voir alors tout le monde peut se tout
le monde peut se rendre dans l'aveugle
chez les oreilles et de dire c'est pas
grave c'est pas grave on verra bien on
verra bien un jour mais on n'a pas le
droit de le faire on peut pas être un
prévoyant avec un système de prévoyance
idéalement quelle serait votre réforme
des retraites à vous c'est un repas ça
passe forcément par un report de la
ville de départ parce que tous ceux qui
veulent uniquement augmenter la durée de
cotisation c'est ceux qui n'ont pas le
courage d'affronter la réalité des des
choses donc on a besoin d'augmenter
l'âge pour que là pour que l'âge pour
que l'âge moyen d'ailleurs l'âge c'est
l'âge auquel vous avez le droit de
prendre votre retraite après vous pouvez
la prendre plus tard vous avez cette
tenue aussi parler durée de cotisation
les deux fonctionnent ensemble il faut
il faut que prendre en compte l'usure au
travail c'est la pénibilité mieux de
façon objective c'est-à-dire médical
médical si vous êtes usé ou par votre
travail c'est normal que vous puissiez
partir plus tôt si vous avez commencé
tôt c'est à dire avant 20 ans il faut
pas changer cet âge là avant 20 ans bon
ben à ce moment là vous avez le droit de
partir par exemple comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui deux ans avant et puis il
faut que les systèmes de formation
professionnelle il faut que les chefs
d'entreprise change leur regard sur la
joue au travail la seniorité au travail
on doit pouvoir encore avoir des
ambitions à 55 ans on a besoin
d'augmenter le volume de travail en
France sinon il y aura pas de création
de richesse il y aura pas d'augmentation
du pouvoir d'achat et on sera dans
l'incapacité de résoudre les questions
de transition vous allez bien compris
que la transition ne peut pas se
financer par la dette nous avons en tout
cas tout ce qui concerne le
fonctionnement
également la transition sociale la dette
elle doit être d'abord elle doit être
aujourd'hui une dette d'investissement
et l'investissement doit se substituer à
la dette de fonctionnement
dans le projet qui va être présenté cet
hiver est-ce que ça a été déjà vu 35 non
parce que vous dites 65 mais ça peut
être avant non je peux faire
pour arriver à 65 faut quand même passer
par 63 et par 64 donc ça veut dire
ans il faut le faire en décalant de
trois mois ou 4 mois on peut d'ailleurs
accélérer cela
doit être 65 ans c'est dans le débat
depuis bien longtemps quand j'ai fait la
réforme Nicolas Sarkozy
peut-être mais alors qu'ils disent non
au système par répartition je veux dire
il faut aller jusqu'au bout des
réalisations si on veut dialoguer alors
il faut aussi un dialogue franc ici si
on considère que la moyenne de vie à la
retraite va dépasser la capacité de
payer les retraites par tous ceux qui
travaillent c'est profondément injuste
on n'a pas le droit de le faire si bien
qu'en France on mêle on met la poussière
sous le tapis maintenant on fait du rire
il y a déjà il y a plus de place pour la
poussière le tapis il est complètement
il est ressemble à un autre chameau donc
il faut il faut absolument être
responsable dans ce la responsabilité
c'est aussi d'accepter le système par
répartition
et la sans doute beaucoup de défauts
mais c'est une magnifique chaîne de
solidarité intergénérationnelle on peut
le remplacer par autre chose partir à la
retraite à la carte ça s'appelle la
capitalisation donc ceux qui veulent
faire vivre une d'abord une réforme de
retraite à la carte dans un système par
répartition faut quand même qu'il
choisisse où est leur camp est-ce que
c'est la répartition ou est-ce que c'est
la capitalisation pour moi c'est la
répartition est-ce que vous pensez que
contrairement au budget on peut sur la
retraite obtenir un compromis au niveau
du Parlement et notamment avec les oui
je pense LR ce que je dis j'ai
suffisamment aussi amener cette
réflexion chez chez LR oui oui bien sûr
c'est cette complètement raccord avec ce
que dit LR depuis longtemps je vois
qu'il y a quelques-uns qui décident de
dire autrement et c'est par manque de
courage c'est juste par manque de
courage et mais faut regarder les choses
telles qu'elles sont c'est pour faire
enfin aujourd'hui on est dans un dans un
monde qui est en train de changer très
vite tout le monde le comprend tout le
monde le voit tout le monde s'en rend
compte
il faut l'accepter il faut au contraire
en faire une opportunité et il faut
avoir beaucoup de courage beaucoup de
courage pour le faire parce que
l'opinion publique parfois n'est pas
tout à fait d'accord et elle est tout le
temps dans le sens de l'opinion publique
quand c'est contraire à l'intérêt
général du pays je déconseille ses
doigts
reculer comme il a fait dans le
précédent quinquennat mais il a reculé
par ce que parce que parce que le covid
est arrivé parce que aussi la réforme
des retraites qui était proposée à ce
moment-là elle était incompréhensible
pour la plupart des Français vous pouvez
pas avoir sur un grand système social
une incompré le rendre incompréhensible
pour les Français
simple et juste que vous parlez DLR et
il nous reste plus beaucoup de temps
Bruno Retailleau qui est candidat à la
présidence du parti a publié une tribune
dans l'Express avec le député européen
François-Xavier Bellamy où il appelle un
devoir davantaire et ici bloque
quinquennat de Nicolas Sarkozy vous avez
été ministre sous ce quinquennat je le
rappelle je le cite mono taillot
beaucoup a été fait durant ces cinq
années mais rien n'a vraiment été assumé
jusqu'au bout la droite avait promis la
rupture elle a fait la demi-mesure
qu'est-ce que vous pensez je sais pas
pourquoi il y a plein sarkozymes
primaire chez un certain nombre de mes
anciens collègues de LR alors j'avais
compris qu'ils avaient abandonné le
gaullisme enfin en tout cas un gaullisme
qui est aussi oppositions
il a une position profondément gaulliste
quand il a considéré que au fond dans
cette son comportement durant l'élection
présidentielle m'a semblée extrêmement
courageux vous pouvez pas laisser aller
comprendre que ça hérite un certain
nombre de tous ceux qui n'ont pas le
courage d'accepter l'idée que LR a loupé
beaucoup de marches alors qu'elle a été
beaucoup prévenue que si aujourd'hui un
champ d'ambition personnelle que chacun
a créé son propre parti Bruno il a son
propre parti
tout le monde a son propre parti avec
Xavier Bertin son propre parti David
Linard son propre parti et ils disent
mon dieu la maison commune c'est
formidable mais ils habitent à côté ils
habitent à côté enfin je comment
voulez-vous sauver les idées de LR parce
que LR c'est d'abord des idées c'est pas
une coquille c'est pas une structure
enfin la structure juridique qu'importe
ce qui compte des idées que nous
défendons les idées que nous défendons
sont ceux d'une droite profondément
républicaines et profondément gaullistes
sociales libéral c'est ça les idées ces
idées elles ont été largement reprises
par Emmanuel Macron qui les met en
oeuvre qu'il est met en a peut-être pour
être en participé à cette mise en œuvre
et peut-être pourrait-on après
participer au fond la transmission de de
d'Emmanuel Macron puisqu'il ne sera pas
à nouveau candidat nous pourrions avoir
ce type de réflexion certains longs
mieux discuter avec le gouvernement et
pas être sans arrêt entre deux champs de
chaises je pense que c'est encore une
fois c'est un manque de courage
fondamental et puis surtout l'incapacité
de regarder la situation telle qu'elle
est quand on fait 4 % des voix à une
élection présidentielle on a le droit de
se remettre en cause et pas uniquement
de dire il faut retrouver des élans
populaires etc enfin tout ça il y a 20
ans il y a 30 ans il y a 40 ans on n'est
pas obligé de rabâcher sans arrêt le
passé plus son j'aime plus rabâche le
passé
les idées des républicains ont un énorme
avenir elles sont majoritaires dans la
population je crois à l'autorité la
nation tout ça
l'entreprise la création de richesse les
droits et les devoirs l'égalité des
chances la République des territoires
tout ça a beaucoup beaucoup d'avenir
mais force est de constater que c'était
manuel Macron qui le met en place il
s'est tant mieux si un président de la
République le fait et qu'il ait une
majorité même relative faut le faire
pour plutôt l'aider non c'est pas
l'intérêt du pays merci
[Musique]